i will tell you uh
ted is he smiling uh he's always smiling
i wore in a dog walk today
shorts and a t-shirt yeah why not here's
why it was 70 and sunny it was real i
walked the dogs too today but i was not
wearing shorts
it was so great for that right yeah you
didn't wear the eight news down muscle
shirt uh no no i don't have it was in
the laundry i don't have the logo or
muscles
i'll tell you what you and everybody
else though loving the weather outside
temperatures were just perfect back to
the 70s these are comfortable 70s
outside some of you got to the 80s over
there today we'll show you where live
look outside of course sun is now down
clear skies should be a comfortable
evening when we get to those 70s your
evenings are in the high 50s so that's
what we're going to see tonight 73
degrees officially our first 70s
of the year 42 overnight for the low way
above our average of 61. the record on
the state 77 back in 2015 last year 68
degrees was our high on this date 69
someone right now 71 for you in
centennial hills aliante same for you
downtown 75 we're double sevens for the
east side sunrise manor and 76 green
valley 72 for henderson and 71 rhodes
ranch and mountains edge currently
outside of town needed spring 69 with 71
for prop and sunday valley and same for
you in boulder city here's our satellite
radar composite high pressure we always
talk about this all right this is over
towards the west of us this is not only
bringing us the mild weather we're
seeing outside but you can kind of see
this flow right here and that's what
we're seeing wrap around this high this
northerly flow which is why we had some
breezes and we'll continue to see some
occasional wind this week too but let's
focus on those temperatures look at a
whole lot of 70s this week peaking on
friday at 74 degrees i checked on those
records however those records are on
78.79 this time here so we don't think
we're going to reach any records and by
the time we get to next weekly after
valentine's day those numbers are going
to dip and drop back to the 60s so get
out there enjoy these 70s while they
last wind forecast breezy winds thursday
and even though we'll have some elevated
winds tomorrow this is where we'll get
the breezy winds here locally and we'll
see it again tuesday signifying the
change in the temperatures with those
gusts next week up to 30 miles per hour
so overnight 45 degrees clear and cool
temperatures will be nice and cool with
light winds tomorrow 72 degrees very
comfortable for tomorrow 10 degrees
above normal and we'll keep around some
of those north breezes like we said but
thursday will be the day we'll see those
stronger wind gusts highs tomorrow here
are your neighborhoods low 70's across
the valley possibly 69 for centennial
hills and 68 for summerlin outside of
town 70's for sure for you in laughlin
boulder city and death valley at 85
degrees tomorrow in the afternoon here's
your eight-day forecast for 8-day setup
like we talked about lots of 70s here
next week they'll change us back to the
mid-60s looking good for the rest of
this week yes guys back to you oh that's
good stuff right there ted